I feel that there's power in the Santa
Claus outfit yeah I mean it's a
fundamentally communist idea right
Santa Claus arbitrary redistribution of
wealth it's not redistribution well at
least I decide who's good and bad only I
only I know this
and I mean I am somehow getting funding
from someone right no
okay listen there's I have so much to
teach you you ever worked little Michael
Workshop yeah and how many people do you
think are employed in this Workshop
they're slaves yes I don't know how many
elves are in the workshop uh I think the
rest of you are gonna have to look into
it now anyway in the red colors and
everything is that the biggest holiday
of all time Christmas like just in terms
of
the intensity of the festivities no I
think Christmas is a very recent
phenomenon I think historically it was
not a big deal now I know historical has
not been but in terms of
how much it captivates how intense it is
I guess from a capitalist perspective
like how much is going on how visual it
is how intense it is I think it grabs a
whole population I think it's because
the idea of Christmas is
probably the one of the most powerful
holiday ideas uh Easter is probably up
there is there's obviously up there
because you have Christ resurrect Christ
dying his resurrection so that's kind of
a big one but but Christmas is this
symbol of Brotherhood and kindness and
magnanimity you know one of the things I
despise about our culture is this glory
and something I'm fighting very heavily
with this book or at least attempting to
is this glorification of cynicism
this kind of like oh you like this song
that's cute stupid
um whereas Christmas is the one time of
year where you could be happy and joyous
and kind and people don't get to roll
their eyes at you they get to stop being
too cool for school and they get to be
like you know I enjoy your friendship
your your my sister my brother my dad my
mom whatever and it's the you know I was
Iran's favorite holiday I adore it and
especially Christmas in New York and
it's just this idea of like even though
we're called and it's dark outside you
know it's still it's kind of like it's
still cozy and you and the next let's
hope the next year is because with with
Russians Santa comes on New Year's so
it's kind of like let's make this next
year an even better one so it's very
much the holiday of Hope and joy
and like love for family for friendship
and kindness and benevolence yeah and
like almost the whole that whole rat
race of uh chasing material possessions
and all that gets put on hold for beef
moment it just all goes quiet but it's
also about giving people material
possessions like here like I value you
this is something that brings you Joy
yeah yeah you write in the book which by
the way
people should go get by right now if you
support this podcast or if you support
the ridiculous office that Michaels wear
wears the more books you buy the more
outfits he is going to wear I've got two
my next two appearances in the show
assuming I don't burn this bridge I've
got some good ones this bridge
has been burning for a long time we've
been going across the road by Kent canoe
at this point next time we're going to
be swimming
um how the hell are you gonna swim
you're made out of
it it's true sink to the bottom get
dragged across by rope